(dramatic music)
(beeping)
- Oh fuck, you're awake.
- Is that a MacRib?
- Yep, you have to wait
a whole nother year
to get one of these bad boys.
- Another year?
Ah fuck, I woke up too early.
Put me back in the
fucking coma, man.
(beeping)
(children laughing)
Are you the Easter Bunny?
- Actually, used to be.
Now I'm the Atheist Rabbit.
Everything you thought you knew
about Easter's lies, fatso.
- You're so cool.
- I am.
- Yeah.
- You know what's not cool?
- The MacRib only being
available for a limited time
when the Big Mac is
available year round?
- Yes.
It's not like he was made
out of Adman's big match,
it was made out of his MacRib.
I have something I
need to show you.
- Show me.
(screaming)
What?
Oh my, fuck you, what is that?
Holy shit.
- Oh yeah.
Yes, yeah.
(laughing)
- Oh my God, this is rabbit.
I think I love you.
- I love you.
- Will you marry me?
- I want you so bad.
- Yes.
- But I just can't.
The president passed a
bunch of wacky laws now.
- What?
- And a man can't
marry a male rabbit
who shits sandwiches.
- No.
That's crazy.
(screaming)
- Send me home.
(beeping)